this video was made possible by skill
share learn for free for two months by
being one of the first 500 sign up at SK
alda sh slash wind over five if you look
at the list of the world's 12 largest
economies there's a clear split six are
relatively small countries where one
could never be more than a few hundred
miles or kilometers from the ocean the
other six the United States China India
Brazil Canada and Russia or enormous
countries with spots more than a
thousand miles or 1,600 kilometers from
the ocean it's well known that ships are
the main method of transport for Freight
globally
thanks to their low cost in fact 90% of
world trade goes by sea while most of
the population lives relatively near the
ocean there are still plenty of
populated areas far inland that too need
a method of low-cost Freight to
transport for that there's freight
trains unsurprisingly those six
physically largest of the twelve largest
economies are rearranged in order the
world's six top users of freight rail
transport to understand the role of
freight rail you have to look at the
numbers in the US it costs on average
about four cents to move one ton of
freight the weight of a small car one
mile on a freight train that's about two
point five cents per ton kilometer what
that means is that on average you could
move one ton of freight coast-to-coast
from New York to Los Angeles on a train
for about $100 it's worth noting that
freight rail prices in the US are among
the lowest in the world
in most European countries for example
they're nearly double in comparison to
those four cents per mile air freight
transport in the u.s. costs about 121
cents per ton-mile or 75 cents per ton
kilometer but air freight is not truly a
competitor to the railways planes will
tend to carry time-sensitive or valuable
goods while trains will carry lower
value or less time-sensitive goods the
true competitor to trains are trucks
which carry a ton a mile at a cost of
around 20 cents or 13 cents per ton and
kilometer this is noticeably higher but
trucks of course can go anywhere
trains can only go where there are
trucks now the reason why trains are so
cheap is because they are quite a bit
more efficient than trucks in 2017 Union
Pacific Railroad as an example moved
Freight
total of 471 billion ton miles that's
the total number of miles multiplied by
the total number of tons moved to do
that they used just over 1 billion
gallons of diesel fuel meaning it took
on average only one gallon of fuel to
move one ton of Freight 469 miles that's
far more efficient than a truck the
reason behind this is simple trains
encounter less resistance their smooth
steel wheels run over smooth steel
tracks so there's very little friction
compared to rubber truck tires running
over the road in addition since the
trains just one long line there's much
less wind resistance per ton than a
truck
a single locomotive uses huge amounts of
fuel but can have upwards of six
thousand horsepower and can therefore
pull a huge number of cars on average in
the US freight trains are about 6500
feet or 2,000 meters long they can get
longer though
in Canada Canadian national regularly
runs fourteen thousand feet or four
thousand three hundred meter long trains
it would take nearly an hour to walk
from one end of this train to the other
typically it only takes two people to
run even these multi mile-long freight
trains considering that most trucks take
one person to transport one container
and these trains can carry hundreds it's
easy to see the advantage in some cases
freight trains are even run by only one
individual the driver of course there
are plenty of safety concerns with that
but railroads are increasingly doing so
as it cuts down on cost overall what
this means is that freight trains are
quite comparatively efficient both
economically and environmentally to
other means of land transport within the
cab of a locomotive there's generally
not much other than the train controls a
few seats and a small laboratory there
are no beds or other accommodations
because crews don't say on board for all
that long every driver and conductor in
a company works a defined territory
along the overall train route so for
longer runs such as BNSF's route from
Seattle to Chicago for example it takes
ten different crews to make the trip the
first takes the train from Seattle to
Wenatchee Washington then switches with
another crew that takes us to Spokane
Washington and then this crew swamp
process repeats itself in Whitefish
Havre Glasgow Minot he still worth north
town and north across before the train
arrives in Chicago in most cases crews
will typically
live at one end of their territory
worked the train to the other end stayin
a hotel overnight then swapped with an
inbound crew to take command of a train
headed back to where they live now under
US law each crew is only allowed to work
for up to 12 hours at a time before
needing a rest period and so these
territories where crew work are designed
to be able to be completed in those 12
hours for longer sections though like
the 276 mile 444 kilometer section from
Glasgow to Minot there's increased risk
of timing out in case of slowdown if a
train crew reaches 12 hours they quite
literally have to stop in their tracks
and wait until they another crew arrives
typically the railroad will drive out a
relief crew from the next stop in this
case my not to take over now there are
two major types of cargo transported by
rail bulk an intermodal bulk cargo is
things like grain stone sand oil and
coal coal along with most ball cargo is
not a value dense product as in it costs
a little to get a lot in the US a ton of
coal costs only $34 on average so of
course you need to put it on the lowest
cost transport method possible which in
many cases is trains trains both serve
to bring coal from the mine to their
domestic destinations mostly power
plants and to coastal ports to be loaded
on ships for international export the
other major type of freight intermodal
involves the carrying of shipping
containers to and from their
destinations generally trains will carry
these containers as only a step in their
overall journey for example a container
might be picked up from a factory in
Shenzhen China brought by truck to the
port of Shenzhen loaded only shipped to
Long Beach California moved onto a train
to Omaha Nebraska before being loaded
again on a truck for its final journey
to Norfolk Nebraska generally railroads
will have their intermodal terminals
where containers are unloaded and loaded
spread out about 300 to 500 miles or 500
to 800 kilometers apart from each other
so the greatest area can be reached
within a day's truck drive from one of
their terminals given the lackluster
nature of the us's passenger railways it
may surprise some that the country's
freight railway system is considered
among the world's best the country is
just in that sweet spot of economically
busy and spread out that supports the
use of freight trains they therefore
serves as a good example to examine to
explain how freight trains work world
mind you SS network is quite extensive
as an example Kansas whose entire
passenger rail network consists of this
has a freight rail network of this what
helps is that in most countries the
government builds tracks primarily for
passenger train usage and freight
operators pay to use them in the u.s.
though it's the other way around in most
cases these track is owned by freight
operators and the government pays them
to use it for passenger operations
through many years of consolidation
seven major freight railroads have
emerged in North America each with their
own territory Union Pacific
BNSF CSX Norfolk Southern Canadian
national Canadian Pacific and Kansas
City Southern with the exception of
Canadian national none operates coast to
coast
so for longer journeys a symbol operator
could not get Freight from start to
finish
now take a look at this BNSF train
you'll notice at the end it's hauling a
CSX car and in Union Pacific car that's
because since no one railroad covers the
entire continent different ones work
together to get Freight to its final
destination a container traveling from
Oakland California to Philadelphia
Pennsylvania for example would be first
brought to Lathrop California where
Union Pacific has a rail yard it would
then be taken off the truck and loaded
onto an eastbound train after passing
through the western United States and
arriving in Chicago the container would
then be removed hauled short distance
from the Union Pacific to the CSX
terminal and placed on a CSX train since
Chicago is as far east as Union Pacific
goes that train would then take it to
Kearny New Jersey near New York City
where it would then be loaded on another
truck to take it to its final
destination in Philadelphia this is
already complicated but it can get even
more sometimes different railroads don't
partner or won't allow for seamless
transfers between certain origin and
destination pairs Chicago for example
has a dozens of different rail yards
used by different railroads so in order
to get a container through one might
have to book a spot on one train to the
city then book a transfer by truck from
one terminal to that of another railroad
then book separately the next train out
of the city this increases complexity
enormous Lee and it's often difficult to
find truck drivers willing to make the
short crosstown trip especially given
the current shortage of truck drivers in
the u.s. many of these complexities are
handled by logistics companies hired by
clients to manage the movement of their
Freight but these interchanges can still
slow down shipping
time's significantly there is this
constant battle between the trucking and
rail industry hired rail lobbyists in
the u.s. constantly work against the
trucking industry by dissuading Congress
from increasing weight and size limits
of trucks with a nearly global shortage
of truck drivers though railroads are at
an advantage right now and many are
thriving new railroads are constantly
under construction worldwide especially
in developing nations and the industry
is growing it's not completely safe
though the advent of driverless trucks
will surely reduce costs and increase
capacity in the trucking industry which
could tilt favor over to the Reppert
iers in addition coal is one of the most
commonly carried goods by freight trains
and as the world transitions towards
renewable energy there could be less
demand for is transportation overall
though at least until there's a
monumental shift in technology freight
trains will continue to be the proven
method for moving Freight long distances
over land if you want to learn how to
make videos just like this one there are
a few things you'll have to learn you'll
have to learn how to write nonfiction
effectively Skillshare has a class for
that you have to learn how to record
good audio Skillshare has a class for
that you'll have to learn how to edit
audio Skillshare has a class for that
you'll have to learn how to animate
Skillshare has a class for that in fact
if there's something you want to learn
there's a pretty decent chance that
skill sure has a class for that you can
take the classes on your computer on
your iOS or Android device even offline
with their app so you can learn whatever
wherever and whenever best of all you
can start learning with scale share for
free for two months by being one of the
first 500 sign up and SK Alto sh / wind
/ 5